how do you get retainers hold your
breath for a long time ah sometimes if
you get like scared like you'll unhit
cup people take your class they collect
ya try to startle me totally works what
is happening reject nation it is Greg
Alba yeah and it's John Humphrey here so
we're going to check out the trailer
they do a trailer reaction for a wrinkle
in time official us trailer released by
Disney if you guys haven't seen that
video that we posted understandable
we're dividing up the reaction and
reviews in separate videos so if you
want to know exactly all the details as
to why you can go watch it there sorry
if it upsets you and also we'll be
giving a shout out to Dylan font Thomas
today for patron of the day anyway
excellent time John's favorite novel of
all time that's right that's correct
I read it so it's my family what if we
are here for a reason - time what if we
are part of something truly divine
imagine 91 billion light years cover
your father has accomplished something
dangerous president he's trapped by
Dogma actively spreading throughout the
universe now the only one who can stop
it if you watch Oprah
[Music]
now she didn't tell much left a cow
[Music]
they have
whoa like black mayor for life
[Music]
the only thing factory like
weirdly like this song over the river
doesn't not make sense only Disney
really knew what that song was about
before putting it over here I don't
think they can well yeah we could give a
quick little thoughts on it and for and
I will do a review in a separate video I
mean look good deal yeah I mean it looks
pretty cool like from my recollection of
the book like there's a lot of stuff
that happens when this is kind of one of
those trailers that shows you more the
places you'll go and let a story you'll
see I mean it looks cool to me yeah that
was a really cool teaser trailer is the
book dark it's definitely like a
harrowing adventure the whole theme is
sort of darkness versus light so there's
definitely a darkness in it I'm
wondering if just because it's a teaser
trailer if it is just you know darker
because a teaser trailer custom teaser
trailers do that sometimes from the
visual standpoint and if it is darker I
would like to see Disney do something
like that I think that'd be really
really cool actually
dark fancy not Alison wandering excited
to see over in a film
oh yeah and yeah I think they're cool
choices for a missus I think they're
called miss whatsit miss who and miss
witch yeah we'll do a full trailer
review on a separate video right now
before we do that before closing out
this video
Dylan Fon Thomas the man who's been a
longtime subscriber of this channel who
also has been part of our patreon since
the beginning who also looks like john
bailey ma'am also sent me some photos of
himself fully clothed Wow because this
all dementedly trailer and I gotta watch
what I'm saying yeah I'm glad you've
been a consistent supporter of the
channel and of our patreon Dylan I want
you to know that when I go to sleep at
night and I hug my pillow I'm imagining
you as John Bailey pretending to be
Dylan Fon Thomas he's doing an
impersonation of you mm-hmm
so John Bailey roles he's never consult
my theory is that Dylan actually doesn't
really exist it's just a character that
John Bailey plays in creating files for
them you know no snapchat face app
things yeah
face on him and then yeah and it lives
like a whole online life you know like
finding channel he likes you know
subscribing to them because you know
John Bailey is really uh insecure about
that kind of thing
pick up anyway you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects you can go check out
our trailer review that it will be
linked probably right now the following
ten screen annotation thing whatever for
probably don't know who knows that John
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram see
you on the other video